[Musique]
c'est le retour des petits jeunes
plusieurs activités gratuites sont
proposées au 11 25 ans cet été au stade
du bois de Maurepas comme une initiation
à Leto un sport qui mêle le combat et la
self-défense on a une approche au niveau
des enfants prioritairement au niveau
des secours le secourisme apprendre à
observer à apprendre à se protéger à ne
pas se mettre en danger et après au fur
et à mesure de l'année on apprend un
petit peu on approche le la self défense
privilégie d'abord l'empathie avant de
se défendre pour être sûr qu'il y ait
pas de souci et que les choses soient
bien comprises ont fait du sport au
sport
pas à l'école voilà et la lucarne
officielle d'Evry était également de
passage à Maurepas le but réussir à
faire rentrer un ballon de football dans
une petite fenêtre
[Musique]
parfois il y en a qui ont un peu de
chance pour se dire il y a un peu de
chance dans tout ça mais oui un bon
niveau de football et un tout petit peu
requis et les morts pasiens étaient
nombreux à venir tenter leur chambre
c'était bien c'était un peu dur mais
faut plus de la procession et j'en ai
pas eu donc j'ai pas réussi mais je veux
repasser c'est bien mais c'est un peu
compliqué faut avoir beaucoup de
précision je trouve que c'est bien que
la mairie de Maurepas nous est
fait ça parce que en vrai il y a
beaucoup de gens qui peuvent pas aller
en vacances cette année à cause de
l'inflation et tout ça et du coup je me
dis que c'est bien parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens qui vont pas en
vacances la troisième édition d'esti
jeune se poursuit jusqu'au 1er septembre
sur le stade du bois au relais Marianne
au min-club et au tridim et il y aura
des activités pour tout le monde les
jeunes les familles mais aussi les
personnes âgées retrouvez le programme
sur le site de Maurepas
[Musique]